vamos a las noticias de la salud con
Mara Romero salamaro Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela hoy con una noticia
más bien preocupante en China vamos a
conocer de su mano la batalla legal de
una mujer que busca poder congelar sus
óvulos a pesar de estar soltera y este a
pesar Pues es lo que genera algo de
angustia el ruido sobre todo No es la
frase que empieza a hacer ruido si es
una práctica actualmente relativamente
prohibida en China que solamente se
permite a parejas heterosexuales que
estén teniendo problemas para concebir
hijos sin embargo no es que sea una
prohibición explícita sino que las leyes
los códigos que existen actualmente
permiten que las Pues los jueces lo
puedan interpretar como una práctica que
va en contra del interés público y de
las buenas costumbres y esta mujer que
se llama Teresa Suzuki o congelar sus
óvulos para tener la posibilidad de
concebir hijos en el futuro una práctica
cada vez más extendida que si bien es
cierto que pone algunas dudas bioéticas
sobre la mesa por ejemplo que abra la
puerta a la comercialización de estos
óvulos congelados o cómo estamos
empujando el límite también de las
edades a las que se pueden tener hijos
la verdad es que en este caso lo que se
mueve no son estas dudas bioéticas o lo
que mueve la prohibición no es la duda
bioética sino la imposibilidad de
concebir la familia o la concepción de
hijos e hijas más allá por fuera del
matrimonio esta mujer Teresa como
decíamos perdió el caso ya en primera
instancia y ahora están en las
audiencias de segunda instancia
escuchemos su testimonio
hay gente que me anima de vez en cuando
y me emociona que haya gente que me
pregunte siento que necesito rendir
cuentas de este evento público que
preocupa a tanta gente Espero que todas
las mujeres solteras que deseen tener
hijos tengan un acceso equitativo a
congelar sus óvulos
sabe que me parece lo más increíble que
china es un país que está a puertas de
una gran crisis de natalidad de la que
se dieron cuenta tarde y están evitando
pues posibles natalidades en el futuro
Claro que las personas que sí quieren
tener hijos no los a raíz de estas
prohibiciones y hablando Pues de los
riesgos de por ejemplo una maternidad
subrogada que que es considerada
violatoria de Derechos Humanos Pues sí
sabemos que entre más jóvenes somos las
mujeres pues mayor calidad tienen
nuestros óvulos no Sí por supuesto es
una práctica digamos que aunque esté en
debate está reconocida en muchísimos
países como una práctica posible eso que
permite al final a las mujeres tener
hijos en los momentos y en las
estructuras que ellas mismas decidan
Claro pero pues como lo decíamos vamos a
concentrarnos en el presente porque esta
es una batalla legal que vale la pena
dar no
vamos vamos entonces a hablar sobre
sobre cómo estas barreras no solamente
existen en China sino también en otras
partes del mundo para acceder a la
reproducción asistida cuando es fuera
del matrimonio sí y no solo hablamos de
congelar óvulos también lo estábamos
viendo por ejemplo en el acceso a la
fecundación in vitro o a la inseminación
artificial que son prácticas que tienen
incluso mucho más recorrido y revisamos
la situación en Europa un país que un
continente que
nuestro imaginario Sería mucho más
garantista en este sentido no tiene por
qué ser así por ejemplo el acceso a la
fecundación in vitro para mujeres sin
pareja se prohíbe en 12 países europeos
y en 16 no se permite la inseminación
artificial sin embargo ahí vemos que
igual todavía la balanza está
equilibrada hacia que hay más países que
lo permiten que países que no lo
permiten es decir un balance
relativamente positivo sin embargo
cuando vamos a ver los casos de mujeres
que están en relaciones con otras
mujeres o que están en vínculos donde la
concepción natural no es posible ahí esa
balanza se desequilibra Y son muchos más
los países que los prohíben que los
países que lo permiten En cambio es
decir una mujer por ejemplo una relación
con otra mujer no tiene acceso en muchos
países europeos en 25 por ejemplo 25 24
según fecundación in vitro o
inseminación artificial si quieren
concebir un hijo sin ir más lejos
Francia hizo sólo el cambio de no
permitir estas prácticas a permitirlas
en junio de 2021 muy lo suficientemente
y todo esto ya sin hablar incluso de las
personas trans cuyo acceso es todavía
más difícil y quería no quería terminar
sin decir que todavía hay países hoy en
día en Europa por ejemplo República
Checa o Finlandia que para hacer el
cambio de género de estas personas se
requiere que pasen por cirugías o
procesos que provocan esterilidad es
decir que se imposibilita ya del todo
que estas personas tengan hijos a través
de métodos que no sean por ejemplo la
adopción que además suele tampoco estar
permitida Y estos mismos países Habría
que ver si estas prohibiciones en el
caso heterosexuales Tienen alguna
relación con esta figura heteronormativa
de un hombre necesario en el seno del
hogar para la crianza si suelen ser los
mismos argumentos al final que se usa
para que estas parejas no puedan adoptar
no al final que igual no sucede mal
porque las mujeres son las que asumen
las labores de Cuidado sean hetero o
sean de otras digamos elecciones de
autopercepción de género vamos a cambiar
de tema para hablar de la relación entre
el uso de las redes sociales y la salud
mental de los adolescentes aquí hay
varias sorpresas sí es un estudio
preliminar Entonces vamos a tener esa
precaución de decirlo publicado en
nature mental Health que estudia este
vínculo y que en este caso lo que hace
es romper una lanza a favor de dejar de
demonizar el uso de las redes sociales
como algo negativo para la salud mental
adolescente escuchémoslo
basándonos en estos hallazgos concluimos
que la representación del uso de las
redes sociales como un demonio popular
responsable del aumento de dificultades
en la salud mental de los adolescentes
es injustificada
de hecho nuestros análisis muestran que
hay otros factores mucho más influyentes
que son candidatos más fuertes a ser
factores de riesgo o de protección
las redes sociales Ángeles lo sabes bien
han cargado con este peso de la opinión
pública y también de la investigación
científica durante mucho tiempo aunque
no podemos sacar todavía conclusiones
ciertas y sabemos que al final las
conclusiones fuertes vienen de acumular
muchos resultados y muchas
investigaciones con el tiempo Vamos a
repasar sin embargo algunas de los
factores de estos que dice que sí
influyen en la salud mental de los
adolescentes este estudio por ejemplo
concluye que en las mujeres se trata
mucho más de la insatisfacción con la
vida laboral o la vida escolar que es
uno de los factores que más influye
mientras que en los hombres se trata más
de el bullying por ejemplo en la escuela
o en los entornos escolares y la falta
de apoyo familiar aquí en estos gráficos
que publicaban en el estudio vemos estas
líneas más gruesas que correlacionan
mucho más apoyo familiar familia vida
con sentimientos como la infelicidad el
nerviosismo o la preocupación y que las
redes sociales que es lo que está
marcado en rojo tienen unos vínculos que
existen pero que son menos fuertes
que me llama la atención que siempre
todo termina en machismo estructural no
tiene una explicación importante Ahí si
no es una sorpresa
bueno es decir como usted lo explica que
los papeles sociales evidentemente
tienen un papel más fuerte en la Salud
Mental que las redes sociales al menos
hasta lo que nos dice este estudio al
menos hasta lo que sabemos ahora sin
embargo por supuesto también hacer la
salvedad de que eso no significa que las
redes sociales o cualquier uso de las
redes sociales inmediatamente sea inocuo
que no sea dañino para los adolescentes
hay otros estudios hay otra evidencia
científica que muestra que por ejemplo
el impacto de las redes sociales sobre
la autopercepción física puede ser
dañina especialmente en estas edades tan
críticas también pueden reforzar
trastornos de sueño no que a largo plazo
tiene impactos sobre la concentración o
sobre la atención y también hay estudios
que han mostrado la correlación entre
más uso de redes sociales más casos de
depresión sin embargo muy importante
decir una relación de correlación en
estos estudios No necesariamente
causalidad lo venimos repitiendo siempre
y también sabemos que las redes sociales
tienen un poder fuerte de visibilización
de debate público que puede ser
favorable pero no queríamos terminar
tampoco Sin dar algunas cifras de que
con redes sociales o sin redes sociales
Hay un problema de Salud Mental en la
población adolescente alrededor de todo
el mundo en América Latina según cifras
de unicef hay 16 millones de
adolescentes de personas entre los 10 y
los 19 años que tienen algún trastorno Y
eso supone el 15% de la población un
segmento muy amplio de la población que
tiene algún trastorno relativo a la
Salud Mental y que además hay cada hay
cada día 10 jóvenes que pierden la vida
por suicidio y es la tercera causa de
muerte entre los adolescentes entre los
15 y los 19 años Eso significa Pues que
necesitamos investigar más Necesitamos
saber qué factores se tienen que atacar
Cuáles son protectores Cuáles son de
riesgo para saber cómo mejorar la
situación algo estamos haciendo mal y
qué bueno que aparezcan investigaciones
como esta gracias a usted mal Muchas
gracias Ángela